how did Ronald Reagan's policies affect
the government and economy what Ronald
Reagan believed is that good programs he
had been a New Deal Democrat he believed
that what had happened was good programs
that had tried to help people who needed
the help the poor the infirm the elderly
those programs had ballooned and what
had happened was they were no longer
prioritizing help to those who needed it
but they had become a kind of system
where those who made the loudest noise
got the most government got the most
money and got the attention from the
government and that that in fact stopped
helping people in need and ended up
hurting people ended up sort of
entrapping them in government dependence
and so what he said was he was going to
do two big things he was or three big
things actually he's gonna cut taxes and
what that was going to do was shrink the
amount of available money towards
government which he was then going to
also do by cutting spending and he was
going to cut regulations so it was
essentially paring down government which
he thought was inefficient towards the
giving resources to those who need it he
wanted a lot of that power to go back to
the states and he also believed in an
economic program that both cut money
from domestic spending but also cut
taxes which he believed would actually
generate more revenue because of
something called supply-side economics
and so his both economic theory and his
theory about shrinking government were
kind of matched up in his first budget
and in his first major tax cut